okay so trying something different for
this one and I am going to watch the
premiere of the Inhumans and I'm going
to record myself doing it and see if
what I get if I can cut it together into
anything vaguely amusing in terms of of
a reaction video or anything like that
so I don't have high expectations going
into this thing so we'll see what we get
I do have on hand alcohol to assist it
is not my intention to get plastered
watching this this is more of a on hand
if I need it now I'll mention also I
don't have any particular invest course
stars in life I don't have any
particular investment in the Inhumans
it's not a series I read it's not what I
care too much about I tried my friend
Brian daily gave me like a real thick
volume of it a while back I got probably
the equivalent of three maybe four
issues into it and it just it wasn't
grabbing me I mean I love lockjaw but
that that's one principle because you
know giant superpower bulldog yeah you
know it's important cuz it's in slow
motion oh it's speed ramped into slow
motion to hold so we're taking our
accused from Zack Snyder always a good
sign you got to throw that in there so
the the DC lovers can hate me right off
the bat that oh that oh that makeup on
him that oh oh god I can see the seams
where the prosthetic oh God oh the slow
motion would be guns and the blows the
suit is actually now actively starting
to annoy me oh oh holy green-screen
that's a lot of hair and you know what
all sudden done the CGI hair is not as
bad here as it was in
trailers well this is a exceptionally
earthy room there's nothing particularly
either high-tech or alien or
otherworldly about the interior of that
world
I mean you pull back you give me the CGI
city okay that's fine that room still
looked like your average yuppie douche
bags apartment I'm probably gonna refer
to him as Ramsay Bolton the entire time
blackbolt is also actually not working
as badly for me now as he did in the
trailers either so this might turn out
not horrible which would actually
probably make for a really boring video
if I if it ends up not being something I
can get properly worked up about and
then in fact just bored by oh the credit
I dread executive producer Scott bog
okay the guy with the tattoos on his
face is immediately annoying okay could
they make up their mind as to what
fashion and adilyn looks like Oh JA CGI
is okay it's TV budget CGI time bulldog
I do love Italian okay where was I okay
yeah so we've got some shots like I'm
looking at this girl and this weird
slightly odd you know design neck piece
thing and walking past her was a guy in
a t-shirt like just a t-shirt I'm going
really quiet because there's not much to
say what I'm looking at right now is not
awful and I'm kind of hoping it either
gets significantly good or significantly
worse because Franco is just kind of
riding competent but dull which is like
the hardest thing to talk about these
extras are awful but whoo whoo see
here's the annoying thing he's obviously
the villain except he can
has a really good point this system
socks and then cuts in this make it
really hard to get a sense of the layout
of the room stop moving the camera leave
it still and just coach stop this is
gonna require assistance
we took hard cider opened with a bottle
opener made by the singing Smith
Nathan Colpitts go back to the really
early videos you'll see him I always
hate it when these sorts of we have this
person's last moments and it's cut
together like a TV show it's like so
that couldn't have been a security feed
that couldn't be through somebody else's
eyes cuz there's cuts and there's angles
like what how are you seeing like how
are you seeing it like it's a movie okay
that wig it looks better when it's
moving in CGI that's your answer
trust your king the man brings up a
perfectly valid point and instead of
explaining why that's not a good idea
you just go trust your King so do these
these people in the white robes they
just sit there forever do they get a pee
break oh god is that way their feet are
in water oh that's not water
Medusa's got some serious eyebrows I
don't know what it is about this angle
there's only making me notice it but oh
boy that was a really operate ugly
unnecessary flashback
we had fun do you remember that the
exposition do you remember
who okay the hair effect a lot worse
here than it was at the start of the
episode did they just like make a point
of putting more time and effort and
making it look good the first time that
we saw hoping that we would accept it
when it happened again and didn't look
as good boy
okay Ramsay's doing his best to cells
but he's having to play against his this
guy boy you know some actors just cannot
deliver still to dialogue
some can breathe life into it he is not
one I must stand Aaron deliver lives
awkwardly another one of these okay I
still don't understand how strictly
within the context of this show how was
Maximus the bad guy everything he's
saying is a really good point and
blackbolt
or those speaking for him have not
offered a counterpoint beyond just trust
me what is this song this hope for God's
sakes stop cutting settle on a shot I'm
gonna start counting 1 2 3 9 10 11 12 21
22 23 song seriously Bulldogs what is it
with these songs god this sounds like
Evanescence or an Evanescence imitator
because I actually like Evanescence can
we get some consistency and whether or
not this is a li to go dude cuz he just
got handed a set of hair clippers it's
like the hair clippers that I I am a
pair of hair clippers like that I should
not own anything that exists in a DeLand
please let the mutants
[Music]
you can't you can't tell me this is an
advanced society barber's clipper that I
could I could find at Walmart for 10
bucks I need him out for drink with a
Granny Smith it's time oh he wound up to
drop an f-bomb you can see any way he
wanted to so bad he can tell he misses
being on HBO where he can swim what
accent is he doing justice wouldn't be
served I'm only halfway through oh dear
ain't only things so far that is saving
this from being iron fist bad is the
fact that there's more characters so I
can't hate any of them as much as I
hated Danny Rand because I don't have to
stick with them like exclusively the way
I did with him yes let's read the sighs
but I do not like my hair cut this yeah
here wasn't good but it was like the
selling point for your character so why
are you here now
I was gonna say the way that they're
cutting around this guy's boobs is
really obvious but that they have a long
shot of him then very clearly he had
normal feet and boots tell me we're not
gonna do a whole bunch of
fish-out-of-water crowd is that that's
where the point where I wouldn't be able
to laugh at a name
that's where we just become painful of
course they knocked the dog out you like
gave it a full sentence of instructions
that's the point we just say lock jaw
leave and then he takes you somewhere
and you you're more explicit
instructions later like what oh our
heroes are dumb there's another problem
with this this has probably been
happening with a lot of so we related
stuff lately the stakes pretty much
everything Maximus has said is a good
point even if he comes off as a bit of a
creepy douche what he appears to be
doing doesn't have other than dethroning
these specific people doesn't have an
immediately negative value if you don't
establish what the threat is on a
grander scale then the only way it works
is if these specific people being
threatened or people I care about and
it's failing on that measure oh you are
the worst Scott buck alright what I was
gonna say before I saw his name flashed
up there three friggin times is they got
their money's worth out of the Hawaii
shooting location I'll give them that
huh so Maximus Elise's he's being taken
this is completely human it's just
interesting because I'm pretty sure he
has like mind-bending powers in the
comics and again it might turn out to be
a ruse but this change is makes me more
inclined to side with him because he
very clearly represents the people who
got the crap end of this deal that keeps
his society running why am I not on this
guy's side stop spinning the camera
around it doesn't make the scene more
interesting he very clearly doesn't have
hooves
stop going to long shots that make it
even more evident that he doesn't have
hogs
now random surfer sure like we're gonna
make that thing out of this whole
aerospace Center lunar rover thing
really
I love how in these kinds of shows
there's always like some NASA day or
whatever like someone basically has
their office in the middle of an
otherwise empty hangar why is this woman
a plot this is insufficient this is a
mug of warm apple cider and this is dunk
smell maple rum whoo more than I plan to
pour quote Doug Walker man's good lay
down my hair we've all had bad haircuts
lady deal with it oh god these lines
again some of these actors can kind of
deliver them some of them cannot here we
go with NASA lady again why what was
that
this show is bad this drink is good
though why they're facing the wall Oh
God and there's one we cannot deliver a
line with any conviction worth a darn
and also the Sun strikes me is wrong
that the a dilantin's have guns same
principle as the guy in the t-shirt and
the Clippers like I it's a society on
the moon give me something more
outlandish sure if you've gotta have
guns make them look really
weird and have the function in a way
that it's believed different from Italy
this is basic stuff there are certain
things about this premise that give you
license to go nuts and they just didn't
really he's kind of wandering to a Men's
Wearhouse okay so they're not doing the
full-on montage but they are doing the
music again the music used in this are
weird and awful and why do we now have
it just in a suit it's like they had no
faith in their own costumes and some
mountain is Black Bolt is not awful I'm
really honestly from the trailers I
thought he was going to be terrible he
is not bad for what is written
don't resist while we beat you okay
serious questions the cops use batons
still because I feel like that doesn't
actually happen anymore but it's a go to
image still and especially if we're
dealing with something that is supposed
to be any kind of a stand in for
minority or people who are different we
have the cops with batons like somebody
tell me our batons still a thing or do
movies continue to keep them despite
them no longer being a thing let me know
in the comments I don't actually care
and this apartment looks like it's in
free in Central Park West design this
apartment that says moon what these
curtains fighter your decorator he sucks
you really gotta make a big deal of the
fact that he hasn't spoken since he
arrested him I mean presumably you told
him he had the right to remain silent
that is a joke sticking its ass six feet
in the air and you still missed it okay
that I can't even remember her name but
this female crony to
Maximillian Maxo whatever she needs to
go away cause she oh that line delivery
harsh the points at which in this action
scene the camera is choosing to slow
down and speed up seem to have
absolutely no correlation to what
moments are more intense or exciting or
would actually look good in slow motion
you're going handheld or whether you're
doing more controlled shots because
switching back and forth from cut to cut
between a shaky handheld and a standard
frame dolly movie how much time is left
in this how good Madusa killed what's
her face was that needed to go away
awesome thank you he did something right
again I'm giving no reason to actually
root for these people besides he's the
game she's the queen monarchies are good
five more minutes
god it's like I've dropped into a
singularity in each seconds is an
eternity wait you just call it a
meritocracy sudamerica nice meritocracy
to caste system look at the same thing a
meritocracy you can work your way up
with merit that's what it means
that's not what this is the super-g
casted okay so now he's delivering a
speech to the undermined and
underprivileged lower classes and why is
he the villain I understand why he is in
the comics in the context of this show
as presented
how is he the villain yeah I'd side with
Maximus oh god she's not dead
that stupid lady Medusa killed can't
deliver a line or at least not a badly
written line worth a darn
Oh God is it over okay
dear God we got a little left but this
thing drove me to it and it just it
started out vaguely in the realm of okay
like not terrible but just like
increasing this it's just so lazy
there's so much this lazy about this the
dialogues it's like somebody had a big
book of dialogue cliches with a very
very weathered spine
scott bach holidayed is pretty important
him under the bus for this but it's just
it's it has a set up that is okay but it
is badly written the stakes are not
established i am more inclined to root
for the villain the favorite thing that
I had in this which was locked jaws
obviously an expensive effect that they
cannot show a whole amount
the production design was just so lazy
like the I'm seeing t-shirts and generic
apartment sets on the moon and they
don't say how long they've been up but
it's obviously been a couple of
generations so you can at the very least
have it be an antiquated earth design
something out-of-date indicate me how
long ago it was that they went there the
fashions at the time that they left lazy
and dumb and black bolts out bad I was
shocked I thought he was gonna be awful
he wasn't bad he didn't save it he
didn't help
he just wasn't one of the weak points
and
Boulton was fine even he wasn't great
but this thing oh god this is a mess I
do not intend to keep watching this
series unless somehow this video like
goes viral and explodes that everyone's
like watch more and get drunk again
maybe but failing that this is it for
for this show for me just heck with you
Inhumans and I'm calling it a night so
that's it let's see how long I can
remember this stuff when I am NOT sober
did you watch the premiere of the
Inhumans if you did I am sorry and also
whatever your thoughts were on it or on
this video drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on itunes on stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned this is obviously just muscle
memory at this point for me night
[Applause]
[Applause]